this woman is trying to tame the tech
giants
[Music]
margareta vestaga views infamous
anti-trust boss
how did i manage you can manage the most
daring tasks
if you dare go go go if you want to
change the world
you need to be in the world
margretovestoga is a leader who's
admired and feared
at the same time for taking up the fight
against big
tech companies sdu's competition
commissioner
and executive vice president responsible
for digital
she's considered to be one of the most
powerful women in europe
one who made it all the way to the top
around the world women still face sexism
difficulties in managing work and family
life
and the gender pay gap to name just a
few obstacles because
the world of politics is still male
dominated
[Music]
more than half of the world's population
is female but women only hold just over
a quarter of seats and parliaments
worldwide
and it looks much worse at the top
currently only 23
of 193 u.n member states have
women presidents or prime ministers
germany is one of them
after more than 15 years in office
chancellor angela marcus era is soon
coming to an end
she's the first woman ever to hold the
post and steal an exception here in
germany
that's why we want to talk to powerful
women in politics
which obstacles did they face on the way
to the top what can we learn from them
and why is it so crucial that women's
interests are represented at the top
margret vestaga is the u's competition
commissioner
some call her the world's most famous
regulator
because she's responsible for
competition and digital affairs with
size
comes responsibility with size also
comes
economic power for some companies to
dominate markets
in ways that threatened fair competition
she brought anti-trust charters against
google
ordered amazon to pay back hundreds of
millions of euros in taxes
and with new initiatives she wants to
crank up the pressure on companies like
facebook a proposal that could
revolutionize the internet some say
for that she's been dubbed a giant
killer dragonslayer and google's worst
nightmare for imposing penalties on u.s
companies
the former u.s president called her the
tax lady
vestiga has received a lot of hatred for
her work
but she continues to follow her mission
to level the playing field
i think it comes with the job because
what i
identify with is to
enable people what what
the the mission that that i've always
been on
into is to say can i enable other people
to see that they have a chance that they
want to take this chance that they want
to make the most of it
and of course in particular people and
smaller businesses
people who may not have you know too
much to begin with
smaller businesses really thrive and to
need some space in order to scale up and
be successful
despite her successes vestiga has also
faced setbacks
a billion euro fine against apple was
later announced
she says that without proper regulation
tech giants are becoming
too powerful and threatening democracy
[Music]
google amazon facebook microsoft and
apple the largest us tech companies are
very male
not even a third of their leadership
position are held by women
because you know i came from the danish
parliament and danish governments
which is not completely gender balanced
but where you do have quite a lot of
women
and i've seen different genders
different generations shaping a society
and now when i look at big tech and see
how it's shaping society
and it's so male dominated
i just think wow we need change we
wouldn't accept it for quarter of an
hour if a government looked like that or
a parliament
looked like tech looks today and and you
know i find that as an encouragement
because if you want to shape the world
of course you need to invite genders on
board different generations on board
[Music]
westergonal had the power to shape the
future for younger women
she describes herself as an introvert as
once
shy girl how did she find the necessary
strengths to become a public figure
first and foremost i realized that
if you want to change the world you want
you need to be in the world
so it's uh it's a side effect
that you need to come out there you need
to engage with people you need to say
who you are
and i try to learn by overcoming you
know smaller
obstacles and then bigger obstacles and
then yet bigger obstacles
by starting like in primary school
raising my hand and say maybe i could
represent us in this classroom
in our student council
and you know it went well
and when you have a small success then
on that you can build the next success
i think the most obvious thing to do is
to
to bring yourself out there not to wait
for someone to ask you uh because if no
one ever
asks you you may never be able to to
engage and achieve what you want to
achieve for yourself and for other
people
so i think the first thing is to say i
will take these steps
and then never refuse an an opportunity
there is these stereotypes that men if
they can you know
tick two out of seven boxes they say
wow this is made for me and women say oh
i only take
seven out of seven boxes maybe i'm not
quite qualified and i think one has to
say no
i may not tick all the boxes but i'll
give it a try
and the worst thing that can happen
usually is a
hurt vanity but you don't die and you
recover and then you try again
[Music]
go go go and second help each other
it's really important to help each other
because sometimes you know there will be
attacks and there will be stupid things
and hurtful things that if you engage
online
and there we need each other
vestiga is one out of 13 female
commissioners in the eu
the first commission in 1958 was an
all-male
affair now almost half of the
commissioners
are women is there a difference between
male and female leadership
i think it gets increasingly difficult
to say
if there is a difference because i think
in the beginning when very few women
uh were holding powerful positions
they were very much like men because
otherwise you would never survive
now we are more but but still not in
balance
so i think you see more different ways
of being a woman with power
but you don't see the full potential yet
uh i tend to think that with
with more women in the room
you get a different sort of game when it
comes to hierarchy
you get a different way of discussing
things
discussion usually becomes shorter and
and the power game not as intense
maybe these are my prejudice
you once said women do not have to
imitate men when they go into politics
but they
should dare to be women what did you
mean by that
well it is as if this is there is this
sort of
power uniform which is a male suit
and and you're supposed to dress like a
man talk like a man
cut your hair like a man in order to be
part of the power club
but the point of of being more diverse
in exercising power is of course the
power should change
so you should not just be the same not
just put on sort of the
equivalent pin skirt uh to the suit
uh not just you know get rid of color
and
and start imitating also because men
knows very well that you're not a man
so why bother and then you can bring
much more
into the power game you can make it
broader you can make it more diverse you
can make it more
accessible if you remain who you are and
that you're different
angela merkel has said she wouldn't call
herself a feminist do you consider
yourself a feminist
[Music]
interesting reaction
[Applause]
[Music]
is
yes i do because for me feminism means
equal opportunity
and it's for everyone it's for men as
well as women
because it will serve men as well as
women when we have equal opportunities
and we have a balanced representation
because then also being a man can be so
much more than a stereotype
and of course being a woman can be so
much more than being a stereotype
okay what i admire in her
is that she's so calm she's so
considered
and and yet she seems to be listening to
all the things going on around her all
different opinions
coming to the table and only when you
know
everything has been put to the table
then she says well maybe this is the way
forward
and i think that is a that's a very good
approach because that creates
ownership for the solutions that we find
but also
it's probably better solutions they have
met on several occasions
well we talked about her office how she
decorated her office and and the views
of her office
this is one of the things i myself
really um
i put an effort when people come to my
office that they
meet part of me they see that i
appreciate the
color and a piece of art on my walls and
all the photographs of my family and my
golden retriever and
so that you that you get personal
because holding power is not about being
a technician
it's about being a human being
westago went into politics in her early
20s for the danish social liberal party
she held several ministerial posts and
was the first
female minister to have a baby while in
office
well it was not the first time someone
became a parent because obviously
a lot of male ministers before me had
become a parent while being a minister
but it was the first time that a woman
as a minister gave birth
and it was a bit sort of people were
well of course it's fine
kind of all right but can it work
and you know if i had a piece of
legislation
in in the assembly hall and the little
one needed
uh to eat i had to go ask each speaker
if i could be allowed to leave the room
for a quarter of an hour
while having someone sitting in there
for me so
you know nowadays how did i manage
but you know you can manage the most you
know
daring tasks if you're there now more
female politicians are
open to bringing their kids to work or
even breastfeeding in parliament
[Music]
westage has three daughters and has
managed to
juggle family and career male in
politics on the other hand
are rarely asked about how they combine
having a family and a job
you know i think it's really a pity that
my male colleagues
are not invited to discuss these things
because it's the thing that everyone
will have to consider
you know of course i have a job and and
a lot of hours go into that and that has
been so for all of my life but you know
many people have that kind of jobs and
have to juggle how to make sure that
you get give your kids what you want to
give them and you have a presence while
at the same time engaging in your job
so it's a really important discussion
and it's not just for women to decide
how to do this
it is for both of us i i i would invite
more men
as as fathers as as uncles as cousins
to come into this debate
[Music]
do we need quotas in business and
politics
i have come to think so um
when i was younger i said oh no no no
quotas this is just for fish
and of course if you are clever and
hard-working and talented you will get
your way
then i realized that men have had
informal quotas for hundreds of years
in formal quotas of 95 98
and it has worked so well for them so if
we really want to change things
of course we also need clothes for
women and men should just be happy that
we settle for 50 50
instead of having 70 percent just for a
couple of decades
but we still have very far to go before
we have
equal representation when it comes to
power
you may be in politics uh you may be on
the social committee
but only when you're also balanced in
the economic committee
we will see that things are shifting
vestiga works long hours
she says cooking baking and sewing help
her cope with the stress
and knitting elephants
well i knit because it keeps me grounded
and you know i can control this itch to
look at my phone
so keep it in the back
and elephants because i really like them
you know they're
they're big they're strong grounded
and they live in a community that is led
by a female
[Music]
a high-profile politician a mother a
feminist who stands up for fair play and
the
balance of power and a strong leader who
is not afraid to show emotion
because she told us holding power is
about
being a human being and what is your
strategy for overcoming obstacles to
achieve your goal
let us know and make sure to check out
our video on svetlana technowska
a woman who dared to take on an
authoritarian leader
in belarus thanks for watching
you